acid-base indicators are used in
titrations to determine when the
equivalence point is reached let's look
at a hypothetical indicator in the
protonated form the indicator has the
formula h-i-n so this would be the
acidic proton on this protonated form
when base is added the protonated form
is converted into the deprotonated form
so we lose an h and we lose a positive
charge so the deprotonated form is
represented by i n with a negative
charge and if we add an h plus to the
deprotonated form we would make the
protonated form of the acid-base
indicator for this hypothetical
acid-base indicator the protonated form
is red and the deprotonated form is
yellow
next let's think about the color of a
solution containing this acid-base
indicator at different ph values
let's say that the pka value for the
acidic proton on the protonated form is
equal to 3 at 25 degrees celsius
and let's say the ph of the solution is
equal to 2.
in that case the ph of the solution is
less than the pka value for our acidic
proton so if we think about the
protonated form being a weak acid and
the deprotonated form being the
conjugate base when the ph is less than
the pka value for a conjugate acid-base
pair the concentration of the weak acid
is greater than the concentration of the
conjugate base
at a ph of 2 we have a lot more of the
protonated form which is red than the
deprotonated form which is yellow
therefore the color of the solution at a
ph of 2 would appear to be red
next let's think about the color of the
solution if the ph of the solution is
equal to 4. since the pka value is equal
to 3 if the ph is equal to 4 the ph is
greater than the pka value
and for a conjugate acid-base pair when
the ph of the solution is greater than
the pka value the concentration of the
conjugate base is greater than the
concentration of the weak acid or as i
have written here the concentration of
the weak acid is less than the
concentration of the conjugate base
so at a ph of 4 we have a lot more of
the deprotonated form which is yellow
than the protonated form which is red
and since we have more yellow than red
the solution would be yellow
finally let's think about the situation
where the ph is equal to three since the
pka value is also equal to three the ph
is equal to the pka value and for a
conjugate acid-base pair when the ph is
equal to the pka the concentration of
the weak acid is equal to the
concentration of the conjugate base
and if we have equal amounts of the
protonated form and the deprotonated
form we have equal amounts of red and
yellow
therefore at a ph of 3 the solution
would be orange
next let's think about the ph range of
the color change for this hypothetical
indicator the approximate ph range over
which an indicator changes color
is equal to the pka value plus or minus
one the pka value for our hypothetical
indicator was equal to three
therefore three plus one is equal to
four and three minus one is equal to two
and two to four is the approximate ph
range over which our indicator changes
color and we already know our solution
with the acid-base indicator in it at a
ph of 2 is red and a ph of 3 the
solution is orange and at a ph of 4 the
solution is yellow therefore if we were
to change the ph from 2 to 4 we would
see the color of the solution go
from red to orange to yellow
now let's see how to choose the right
acid base indicator for a titration our
goal is to choose an indicator whose
color change occurs as close as possible
to the ph of the equivalence point for a
weak acid strong base titration the
equivalence point occurs at a ph greater
than seven first let's look at the
acid-base indicator methyl red methyl
red has a ph range of approximately four
to six so a little bit over four methyl
red starts to change from red to orange
and then eventually to yellow by the
time you hit a ph of about six however
the ph of the equivalence point for this
titration looks to be somewhere between
eight and ten
therefore if we used methyl red and we
stopped the titration when the color
changed we'd be stopping the titration
too early so we might be stopping it
somewhere in here before we reach the
equivalence point so methyl red would
not be a good choice as an acid-base
indicator for this titration another way
to think about this is with pka values
for methyl red the pka value is
approximately 5 and the goal is to match
the pka value as closely as possible to
the ph of the equivalence point but
since the ph at the equivalence point is
between eight and ten that's too far
away from five so by looking at the pka
value we know that methyl red is not a
good fit for this titration
phenolphthalein is an example of another
acid-base indicator and has a different
ph range at a ph of about 8
phenolphthalein is colorless however as
the ph changes from 8 to 10
phenolphthalein goes from colorless to
pink
because the color of the indicator
changes in the same range where we would
find the equivalence point
phenolphthalein is a good choice as an
acid-base indicator for this titration
and thinking about the pka value for
phenolphthalein which is approximately
nine that falls in the range of eight to
ten where we find our equivalence point
so we could think about it either in
terms of the ph range or the pka value
next let's choose an indicator for a
weak base strong acid titration for a
weak base strong acid titration the
equivalence point occurs at a ph less
than seven
if we try to use phenolphthalein for
this titration remember phenolphthalein
changes from eight to ten or in this
case it'd be changing from
10 to 8 so we'd start at this relatively
high ph here and if we try to use
phenolphthalein and we stopped it when
the color change occurred we'd be
stopping the titration too early so we
might be stopping the titration
somewhere in here so phenolphthalein is
not a good choice as an acid-base
indicator for this particular titration
thinking about using pka values the pka
value for phenolphthalein is
approximately nine which is not a good
fit for the ph at the equivalence point
which appears to be between four and six
methyl red has a ph range of about four
to six over which it changes color and a
pka value of approximately five and
since the equivalence point the ph of
the equivalence point is between 4 and 6
methyl red would be a good choice as an
acid-base indicator for this titration
so to summarize when choosing an
acid-base indicator for a titration
choose an indicator whose color change
occurs as closely as possible to the ph
at the equivalence point